what I know what's heating up theaters  this weekend in Annabelle creation a  doll maker and his wife welcomed  orphaned children into the remote home  where an evil presence resides from  living in the glass castle based on a  true story a young woman must come to  terms with her unconventional parents  honestly tell me animals must take back  their home from humans who want to make  it an amusement park in then that job  too nutty by Nature  roll over I don't know how I'm not  classically trained see what's hot in  theaters with this week's fantasy facie  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]